good afternoon everyone
my name is dr miller and the scp we're
going to be looking at today
is scp-1498
object class euclid
special containment procedures all
instances of scp-1498 are to be held in
standard containment chambers
located within site-77 one technician is
to be on hand to answer any calls placed
to scp-1498
transcripts of all calls must be placed
in site-77's non-anomalous records
archive
any persons found to have interacted
with scp-1498
are to be quarantined for two months or
until they show signs
of scp-1498 subjects showing signs of
exposure are to be contained as an
instance of scp-1498-1
which require the same accommodation as
instances of scp-1498
description scp-1498 is a collection of
30 autonomous bundles of phone cords and
handsets assembled in such a way that
they resemble sheep
instances of scp-1498 are fully
ambulatory and will wander their
containment chambers aimlessly
the words make your own custom
dreamscapes with your friends at the
oneroy collective
are printed on each instance if a
sapient organism attempts to use one of
the phone handsets present on scp-1498
they will hear three rings followed by a
voice
identifying themselves as an operator
for the oneroy collective
this voice will instruct the subject on
various options they have for dreaming
and make suggestions for enhanced
dreaming experiences
following the completion of this call
the subject will lose consciousness for
9 hours
when the subject regains consciousness
they will claim to have experienced the
dream they ordered
to any exact specifications they have
made
subjects may express a desire to
continue using scp-1498's effect
or attempt to reuse it immediately a
transcript of a subject describing their
experience while under scp-1498's effect
has been included
in this report the following is an audio
recording
of d4560 after being exposed to scp-1498
i was sitting in this room except it
wasn't really a room because the edges
were sloped so it was like a
an egg room with green paper
but it wasn't that green just a little
green here and there
anyways i'm right in the middle sitting
on the ground
except of course the fact that i was
being supported
it's then i realized that i'm actually a
table
like you guys told me to tell the weird
cheap phone thing
there's people eating off of me too look
old maybe from the 1950s with red faces
that was when we finally hatched and i
woke up
as subjects are repeatedly exposed to
scp-1498
they may begin to experience changes to
their bodily and
mental state subjects affected by
scp-1498 will express a desire to sleep
as frequently as possible preferring the
use of scp-1490
if they are able to while asleep
portions of the subject's cranium and
skull will be replaced with portions of
telephones
similar to those found on scp-1498
this has manifested in a variety of ways
including
subjects coughing up telephones with
cords extending into their esophagus
telephone wires beginning to grow in
place of hair
ringing devices found on rotary
telephones found within the subject's
ears
which may begin ringing continuously and
vocalizations being replaced with dial
tones
eventually a rotary phone will assemble
itself on the subject's head
out of all the components that have been
grown within and on their bodies
subjects will display the same
intelligence as instances of scp-1498
and are to be classified as instances of
scp-1498-1
as of august 19 2012 no attempt to
restore the intelligence of an
scp-1498-1 instance
has succeeded scp-1498 was recovered on
september 18
1965 from an abandoned office complex in
miami florida usa
after reports of bizarre livestock
reached local foundation assets
when foundation agents entered the
building they discovered the scp-1498
instances
one bedroll approximately half a ton of
rotary telephone components
and two pints of type a b blood in a
glass jar
in addition one pajama onesie well worn
was discovered folded at the bed roll
testing has shown several months worth
of sweat and body oils
soaked into the fabric
as of november 14 1965 scp-1498
has been classified as euclid
so i figured that since they were
covered in this lecture i would give you
a little background information
on the waneroid collective oc
or the oneroy collective is a hivemind
entity located in metaphysical space
it is a collective unconscious utilizing
the brain power created by sleeping
things
it has been known to manifest in
physical space as inanimate and organic
objects which
interact with dream space in a way that
favors oneroy
this has been disputed by some as
identifying favorable outcomes implies
an obvious motive
or method of behavior neither of which
has been conclusively found across
scholarly studies
of oneroid any schemes motivations or
specific entities identifying as part of
wonoroi
are unknown and probably don't exist
formats to interact with the collective
have been documented to resemble
contemporary media outlets
this has been confirmed as a lie the
cornfields of the mind are too vast for
any trawler to manage on their own
the interfaces are not of the world they
are a reflection of you
you are too shallow to get it in return
locations where wanaro
exists includes all of them to be less
general
here is a list of where some are in the
cold spots of the world that only the
hardy can survive it
they are known to have many occurrences
of dreams containing sunshine
kisses in their margaritas king louis
xiv
of france both before and after he lost
his virginity
every bar stool rick di pietro's broken
dreams and the shattered hopes of the
entire new
york islanders hockey club fanbase scott
wilkins
and all the people of scotland from the
highlands to all of your diaspora in the
lower hares
we have you scotland you are ours
the first known mentions of the waneroy
collective can be found in classical
greek mythology where it was a
dream-related entity
since then it has been found throughout
everything
it got into everything before we even
knew about it
there are many contemporary
organizations with members participating
in wonoroi
and few of them are even aware of it
there are many negative consequences to
these and your actions with the
collective
if you suffer from its grasp that sounds
bad
in 2014 the one arroyo collective was
nominated for the 121st annual
gccx award for absolute [ __ ]
pointlessness
wanna roy west is the largest most
coherent collective of one arroyo in
existence
it consists of visiting dreaming humans
and
pure oneroy who have abandoned their
bodies completely
members of one arroyo west have autonomy
and sense of self
existence in waneroy west is generally
considered favorable to other large
collectives
however the great consciousness that
their minds form
an entity in itself something like an
avatar
does not allow them to die this is a
serious problem as many waneroy have
grown bored with immortality
jupania is a xenophobic disconnected
hivemind contained for the purposes of
your narrative
within a few hundred humans each oneroy
located within this collective is an
inferior copy
of qui xiao a former human and creator
of jupania
jupanian realms are all identical
hostile realms
filled with night terrors jupanians are
not actively aggressive toward other
collectives
unless antagonized think of them like a
beehive
monoroy collective a mysterious
massive collective that many wanneroy
believe inhabits the majority of earth's
flora
and fauna not much is known about
wannaroy who joined the wanneroy
collective are never heard from again
and those that manage to return are
twisted amalgams of
many different things shadow
woneroy a person's subconscious
their dream self appears as the guest
alt of a person's identity wanna roy
generally refer to other vonorroy by
this gestalt
because they appear as such for example
there is a down on his luck human named
bob stevens
while dreaming he is an ambulatory
footstool
referred to as quad pedal doormat
any group of minds can be a collective
say the maxwellians learned how to
become oneroy
there might be a maxwellian collective
or an are we
cool yet collective
okay thank you for listening if indeed
you still are
and you are all dismissed goodbye
i would like to give a special thank you
to bad luck lou
it's not a spoon arbiter's soul
the morrigan james saba
nicola w joker corvus
kawaii fire keeper king madding
samurai corgis daniel
nj vujak justin day
and eric corbich if you would like a
special thank you at the end of each of
my videos and some other cool stuff as
well
visit patreon.com forward slash the
vogen
thank you
you